last weekend war zone fans settled in
for part one of the world series of war
zone qualifiers everyone was looking
forward to a fierce and fair competition
to decide who advances to the finals
instead the whole thing was derailed by
widespread accusations of vpning stream
sniping and friends feeding kills to
each other let's untangle this whole
mess
vpns feeding kills and stream sniping we
really do have the holy trinity in
today's video if you enjoy hearing about
that kind of stuff when it happens then
make sure you're subscribed to the score
esports and if you enjoy the video at
the end of it make sure you leave us a
like on your way out the door appreciate
it all right before all this it had been
nine months since the last world series
of war zone event so as you might expect
fans were absolutely chomping at the bit
to see this event get started activision
have laid out a 300 000 prize pool for
teams competing in both europe and north
america for a total prize pool of 600
000
40 trios are competing in the open
qualifiers only 20 will make it through
to the finals but they then have the
chance to compete with 20 invited trios
to get their hands on that fat prize
money the scoring and rules for the
event are as follows and remember these
because they will be important later the
scoring is based on each squad's total
kills and placement in each map of play
players get a point for every kill and
additional points for teams based on
each of their squad's individual
placements then there are the
multipliers 16 to 40th place gets no
multipliers second to 15th get a 1.5
multiplier to their point first place a
whopping times two multiplier the
qualifiers are an open bracket anyone
could join it not just your usual scumps
and swags who get invites on paper this
seems like a great idea it increases the
chances of upsets dark horses and
underdog stories and who doesn't love
that but we wouldn't be doing this video
if things panned out like that because
unfortunately if there is a way for
players to manipulate a system some
often do you see warzone like a lot of
games has a matchmaking system you're
supposed to be mashed up against players
of equal rank and skill including in
this qualifier but not too far into the
tournament at all accusations began
flying around that some of the players
were using a form of vpn abuse called
geofencing youtuber the tactical brit
explained just how this
everything up what geofencing does is
prevents the game client from connecting
to various servers that call of duty has
available and in doing so prevents it
from being able to use skill based
matchmaking after about a minute and a
half to a minute and 15 seconds of
matchmaking call of duty automatically
gives up its skill based matchmaking
protocol allowing a player to get into a
game even if they're not necessarily
meant to be in that lobby so essentially
the game will deprioritize skill based
matchmaking after a certain amount of
time just to get a game going in this
tournament the belief was that higher
skilled players were able to get into
lower skilled lobbies through
geo-fencing and just clean up the
competition and because the tournament's
point system counts every kill the same
they racked up monstrous scores that
they probably wouldn't have got if
matchmaking was working as intended the
result was that these players were
getting closer to playing in the finals
against the best in the world with
scores that massively exaggerated how
good they actually are but all of this
wasn't even half the problem at the
tournament there were also accusations
that players were getting their friends
to join an opposing team in their
lobbies once they were in game the
friend would just die over and over
again to that player pushing them right
up the leaderboard one reddit post
shared some screenshots that show some
suspiciously high scores on one side
accompanied by some unbelievably bad
scores on the other one player getting
75 kills while their opponent died 34
times you get the picture a comment
suggested that the only realistic
explanation was that the second place
team was working with the first place
team to feed one of their players a huge
amount of kills get the win and the
multiplier that came with it and the
players being accused weren't total
randoms either one of the names in that
screenshot you just saw was mad lions
player javiks warzone streamer fifa kill
pointed this out on twitter and referred
to this as shameless he also got called
out as desperate by warzone streamer
porky9 and apparently in a later deleted
reply javik simply said that quote
everyone wants a spot the 75 kills that
the boosted player got might be enough
to get them into the final against some
of the best players in the world so you
can kind of see the problem here aside
from geo fencing and feeding kills a
third accusation flying around was that
streamers were being sniped in this
situation streamers were stuck between a
bit of a rock and a hard place on the
one hand they obviously want to stream
themselves playing one of the biggest
warzone events of the year but a number
of streamers felt they were being
targeted by players who would get into
their games on opposing teams ignore
everyone else and just hunt for that
streamer so to put it simply a lot of
warzone fans are unhappy with how this
tournament is panning out especially
because it has a knock-on effect the
invited trios are invited because
they're known to be absolute demons at
war zone there was excitement before
about seeing these pros face off against
hidden talents to battle their way
through the qualifier but that's going
to be tarnished now because a huge
shadow will be cast over the legitimacy
of the players who make it out of the
qualifier that sucks for those who don't
vpn abuse or feed kills to friends and
miss out on a spot because of that but
it also sucks for the ones who
legitimately qualify too because they're
gonna be doubted and of course it sucks
for the viewer too there's a good chance
that the invited trios are gonna
absolutely mop the floor with anyone who
didn't earn their spot in the finals
fairly this weekend we've got the second
part of the qualifiers for na and eu
we've had no word from activision so far
on what they're doing to address the
community's concerns here or to be
honest even acknowledge the existence of
them there's a chance we'll see more of
the same this weekend and if the drama
flares up again we'll be sure to let you
know
check out my excessive four liter water
bottle i got four liters i mean you're
supposed you know what's crazy you're
supposed to drink this in a day you say
it starts with 7 a.m finishes with 9 p.m
i think i get kidney failure if i tried
to drink that in a day